this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah okay great so my name is Cedric
Mason I work with the New York State
soil health initiative also with David
Wolfe who's a PI on the project and
we're working with policymakers
researchers nonprofits all types of
stakeholders in the state who are
interested in soil health to try to
improve soil health all across the state
of New York which is a little bit
complex because New York has so many
different types of crops so soil health
is important because it supports food
production for us most of the food that
we eat comes from soil it plays a large
role in protecting our water resources
and it also has the potential to help us
mitigate climate change so some of the
benefits of healthy soil especially with
regard to food production which we're
going to focus on today healthy soil has
high levels of organic matter which help
retain retain soil moisture retain water
in the in the soil for crops to use it
also supplies nutrients for those crops
it feeds an intact soil microbiome which
can include things like earthworms
insects bacteria and other microbes and
it can healthy soil can also also
function to protect against crop
diseases that could negatively impact
these food crops and finally a healthy
soil provides a wide range of pore sizes
which are conducive to both water
holding capacity and also routing and
drainage but in New York a lot of or a
few things can go wrong with with with
maintaining our soils so when we're
driving these heavy tractors over these
soils it's compressing the soil making
it hard and difficult for water and
roots to move through that soil then
what happens is we end up with some
erosion that can carry nutrients the
sediment off the field into waterways
which has other negative impacts off the
farm
and tilling can also result in loss of
organic matter through oxidation and
make it difficult for some of these for
the soil microbiome especially
earthworms are impacted by tillage and
some of these fungal networks that can
transport nutrients to plants are also
affected so why do we tell to begin with
a big part of it is to break up
compaction and that initial tillage
creates conditions that that sometimes
perpetuate the problem so compaction if
we treat that compaction with tillage
we're burning off some of that organic
matter oxidizing it quickly we're
feeding unhealthy microbial communities
we're breaking apart those soil
aggregates that provide the soil
structure and provide the drainage that
we need and then that soil gets
recommand we need to plow again so we're
trying to break this cycle and find
other ways to produce the crops that we
need to eat and also maintain these
other benefits that soils are giving us
so specifically we're looking at these
three three practices reduced tillage
cover crops and organic amendments which
include compost manure and biochar so
reduced tillage has the benefits of
preserving these these the microbiome in
the soil preserves the macro pores we're
not disturbing the soil as much and
we're also retaining out organic matter
which stores carbon provides nutrients
to the plants and also the microbes in
the soil and in addition off the farm
when we start to look at the impacts of
reduced tillage we're saving on fuel
because we're not driving our tractors
as much we're saving on time and labor
and we're saving wear and tear on our
equipment so there's other benefits as
well when we look at cover crops we're
looking at the on the rooting action of
these plants can both break up hardpan
break up compaction that allows the soil
to absorb more water to transmit it to
the water table we're adding organic
matter from the from the plant material
that's returned to the soil if we're
growing a leg ooh like in the bottom
left corner this is a pee cover crop mix
legumes can provide nitrogen in the
soils by absorbing it from the air and
through nitrogen nitrogen fixation and
there's really a wide variety of
applications and types of cover crops
and depending on what crop we grow we
can be providing forage on farm animals
and also producing Co products like for
example sunflower seeds but in this
climate we have this long winter gets
pretty cold and there's some challenges
to getting these crops established and
getting the benefits that they can
provide especially over the winter only
about 10 percent of New York State
cropland is currently cover cropped or
at least it wasn't 2012 maybe that
numbers up a little bit and there's a
challenge to get these cover crops
established and fit them in with the
rotations of the other crops that we're
trying to grow because corn and soy
usually come off they're harvested in in
the fall and that at that point the
growing season is winding down and it's
really difficult to get plants
established at that point so there's
some research looking at interceding
which is involves planting these cover
crops between the rows of corn or
soybeans to get them established earlier
and finally we're looking at these
organic matter amendments where we're
taking oftentimes waste waste products
crop waste or food waste creating a
valuable compost or biochar from them or
in the case of dairy farms manure and
these can be applied to the soils and
and adding organic matter back into the
soil and this provides nutrients for the
crops as well as the the microbes which
in turn help help preserve the soil
structure and these also have the
benefits of reducing co2 and methane
that might come from improper
position of these materials so what I'm
going to talk about today is looking at
some of the benefits costs and
constraints that farmers see when
they're trying to when they're trying to
implement these practices because a lot
of them are coming from a place where
they haven't been using cover crops they
haven't been reusing reduced tillage and
it's a big challenge for them to to sort
of change the direction of the ship so
to speak a lot of times they're running
a business a lot of farms in this
country or our businesses so they're
trying to make money and trying to pay
their bills just like the rest of us so
we really looked closely with this study
excuse me it looked closely in the study
about at the financial picture these
farmers are seeing so one of the tools
that farmers can use when they're trying
to plan ahead and and evaluate potential
changes and they're in their practices
is that they can use this this framework
called the partial budget analysis and
the partial budget analysis looks at the
expected change in their business that
would come about when they use these
practices so it could involve extra
expenses that they weren't seeing before
it could involve extra benefits that
they weren't saying seeing before and so
here I've outlined these a bit for you
and we can see the green the green
examples here are examples that would
positively impact business for example
less fertilizer less pesticides that's
less money you need to spend on those
inputs also we might be seeing greater
yields and that can increase income so
again it's kind of we're looking at both
the positive and the negative aspects of
these changes and then over here we see
the negative aspects which might include
extra cost for cover crop seed or
special planting equipment
and you might have to take some land out
of out of rotation to plant those cover
crops and grow them for a year or so to
get your soil health going so we're
looking at all these different factors
and so there's there have been some
studies that have used this partial
budget analysis and looked at some
specific farms this is an example of a
case study that was done by a company
called dot to research on a farm this is
a corn and soybean farm in the Midwest
and so here you can see they did a
five-year study one two three four five
and you can see that there's an initial
cost in this case kind of an investment
if you will and then after a couple
years that investment starts to pay off
and you can track the net benefit here
and and see that a little bit down the
line there could be some real benefits
to this which is great because these
practices also provide these
environmental benefits these climate
mitigation benefits so if we can make
these if these practices can be
profitable to the farmer it can be good
for everybody
right it's a win-win situation so what
we do is we we want to capture more than
one farm in this state we want to
capture the whole state we wanted to
identify with this survey identify the
specific cost that farmers were seeing
and the specific benefits that they were
seeing we wanted to encompass all of the
all the types of farms in the state
including different levels of experience
different crop crop types different
systems organic conventional different
farm sizes we saw we actually saw farms
from I think the smallest was like point
1 acres up to like 5,000 acres so this
is really a broad broad survey that I'm
going to present here and finally we
also want to see how these how improve
soil health might help these farms help
farmers weather the storm if you will by
being able to sustain crop production in
adverse years where there might be
flooding or there might be odd droughts
so what we do is we conducted the survey
we distributed paper copies of the
survey which actually I have some
leftovers here if anybody's curious to
just check it out feel free to just stop
by and I'll give you one and we also
used an online platform called Qualtrics
where respondents could access the
survey online and just take it from the
comfort of their own home which was
actually a really great great way to go
a lot of a lot of responses came in that
way so we looked at these three
practices reduced tillage cover crops
and soil amendments and we asked farmers
questions about their practices and the
benefits that they were seeing and
statistically we used the type the
chi-square test to evaluate some of
those associations between say a
cropping practice and the benefits so we
received 182 respondents from all over
the state this is just a map showing
sort of the geographic distribution of
the responses that we received we got
really a good response rate in a lot of
the heavy agricultural areas here on in
western New York so the response rate
correlates pretty well with the
agricultural districts across the state
46 counties accounted for over one
hundred seventy two thousand acres so
the first question on the survey was
really what constraints do you see to
crop production on your farm and this is
how farmers answered so the most the
most frequent answer actually they could
check off multiple answers but the most
common answer was for drainage second
was compaction and third was erosion and
this is interesting because these are
all three constraints that could be that
can be addressed with soil health
practices
and then you can see others here so we
were interested in determining farmers
who use these reduced tillage practices
what are they spending their money on
what are the what are the investments
required and also what are the benefits
that they're seeing so this is the
results of the reduced tillage pool
there were a hundred and forty nine
149 responses and of course this adds up
to more than 149 because a lot of the
farms were growing multiple crops with
reduced tillage but we can see that the
most the most popular crop here is corn
and soy for feed followed by grains oil
seeds dry beans the gray bar
alfalfa pasture hay basically forage is
a big one and vegetables the very common
in the reduced tillage group so the
number one cost that we're seeing these
farmers spend that these farmers are
seeing a specialized tillage equipment
about half of them reported spending
money on that or at least encountering
that obstacle and then along with that
specialized planning equipment a lot of
times if you're doing reduced tillage
you might be trying to plant through a
sod residue so you need a special grain
planter that will help you plant your
crops through that and then if you're
reducing tillage you're reducing them
you're eliminating that mechanism of of
weed control and so you might be
spending great more money on herbicides
and then of course their additional
compounds down here increased labor
lower yields but these are the three big
ones and so what we did is we compared
some a couple of different rock types so
the yellow bar here represents farmers
who only grow corn and soybeans with
reduced tillage and the green bar is is
farmers who only grow vegetables with
reduced tillage and then the gray here
is the yellow so we're looking at
specialized planting equipment and we're
seeing that overall around 50% of people
our farmers are using this are requiring
planting equipment but the vegetable
growers really are not reporting that as
a cost I think that really reflects
their their cropping system maybe a lot
of them are organic and they're planting
doing transplants by hand or they can
use their existing transplanter so
they're not really seeing that as a as a
big obstacle for them another
interesting one was you can see that
overall here
increased labor was pretty low really
only maybe 13% of the farmers said okay
to do reduce tillage I need to put in
more labor and very clearly corn and soy
growers are not putting in more labor to
reduce their tillage in fact it's the
opposite for them but vegetable growers
are reporting this expense at a much
higher rate so almost 40% of vegetable
growers doing reduced reduced tillage
you're saying yeah I got to work a
little bit harder maybe I'm cultivating
more often or I'm hand weeding I'm
moving tarps around something like that
and this is a this is a pretty
significant p-value from our chi-square
test you can see that's a big difference
so we're pretty sure there's a
difference there between the vegetables
and the corn soy growers looking at the
switching to the benefits that these
farmers are seeing from their reduced
tillage practices less erosion and
sedimentation repair is a big one in
some cases if erosion is happening the
soils basically moving from from the
field into their drainage areas and a
lot of farmers have to run their tractor
and kind of move that soil back they
might have to fix some some rails and
gullies so that they can drive their
equipment across the field so this is a
big benefit for them 83% said that this
was a benefit and then
contrast to the increased labor that we
saw among the vegetable growers 74% are
saying yeah and send I'm spending less
on labor fuel and equipment I'm not
driving my tractor as much not not
driving that tractor myself as much and
then interestingly over half said I'm
also getting greater yields so the
benefits are real and then there's also
a lot of other ones of what is drainage
of best avoided drainage investments
less irrigation maybe they're building
their organic matter so their soils
holding onto water better they don't
have to irrigate as much it could be a
savings and then looking again at the
the differences between these crop types
we're looking at greater yields that was
around about 52% overall
let's see here but maybe not quite as
prevalent among the corn and soy growers
as it is to the vegetable growers I'm
not quite sure why that is
this isn't actually statistically highly
statistically significant so it could be
an artifact looking at lower fertilizer
input corn and soy growers they're you
know they're saying no I still got to
put the same amount of fertilizer on but
vegetable growers are seeing a benefit
here and this is fairly significant here
the 0.05 p-value and then finally to
wrap up this section on reduced tillage
we asked about the profitability and I
think the main picture here is that very
few farmers are saying this is
decreasing my profitability so
overwhelmingly the majority are finding
this practice beneficial to their
business which is good so now we're
going to switch a little bit and look at
cover crops so just to kind of recap
again the cover crops are planted
between crops to protect the soil
provide feed organic matter back into
the soil and this was the breakdown of
our the pool that we saw responding to
our cover crop practices there were 125
farms that we saw doing cover crops
number one again is this corn soy and
then followed by vegetables surprisingly
so vegetables are out there and then
grains and oil seeds dry beans is the
gray bar here number three and again
yellow Falcon pasture hey
followed by some of these other minor
crops here
so prevalent costs and decreases in
revenue from cover crops the big one
here is cover crop seed so I think this
indicates the very few farmers are
actually growing their own own cover
crop seed which isn't really surprising
I think that would be a kind of a
complicated operation but maybe some of
them are doing it cover crop
determination is a big concern among
people growing these cover crops because
if that cover crop goes to seed and you
can't you can't kill it and that seed is
in your soil and it could interfere with
your cash crop so cover crop termination
costs not surprising that's up there
there's different ways of terminating a
cover crop you could let it winter kill
which is just to let the cold kill the
crop some crops like radishes winter
kill by themselves so you don't have to
worry about that too much
you could mow it which might kill some
cover crops you could spray it spray it
and burn it down with herbicide and you
can also roll it if you're usually if
you're doing an organic of an organic
system which has its own challenges so
these are sort of the items that would
negative affect negatively affect a
business that's doing these cover crops
and it's also interesting to look at
some of these additional ones too people
might be putting in more labor to get
these cover crops in or spending time
learning about how to how to do it cover
crops is a pretty tricky thing at the
timing is really important the type of
cover crop is really important so
there's there's definitely some other
considerations in there too and we
didn't actually see any coming back to
this one we didn't actually see many
differences between the crop types in
the costs these cover crop supplies so
so we can switch threats right to the
benefits of cover crops so looking at
these benefits less erosion is a big one
83.9% are claiming less erosion from the
recovered crops which if you remember
that was one of the top three
constraints that farmers were also
reporting so this is cover crops are
really a great tool to combat this
erosion cover crops can actually reduce
her actually result in greater yields
maybe they're providing better drainage
and therefore your crop is growing
better it's getting a little bit more
nutrient cycling going down it going on
in the soil could be returning the
organic matter and also lower fertilizer
inputs can result from these cover crops
maybe that's from simply the organic
matter that's being built up and
returned to the soil or it could be
because they're growing a legume cover
crop that's fixing that nitrogen in the
soil and this one really has a whole lot
of whole lot of other minor
considerations here easier faster
harvest could be a big one if you can
get your equipment in there at the right
time because your soil has drained
adequately that that could that could
make your life a lot easier and but we
did that we did see some more
differences between these crop types
these benefits of cover crops looking at
the greater cash crop yields we see
overall right around 50% of reporting
that but not as many corn and soy and a
whole lot of vegetable growers are
saying greater yields of cash crops
decrease fertilizer inputs similar
picture again the vegetable growers
really responding to that item
and I think this could be due to maybe
the types of cover crops that vegetables
are likely to grow I think corn and soy
growers they're probably either taking
land out of rotation for a year to grow
something or they're trying to they're
doing a grass like triticale or rye in
the fall to get that overwinter cover
and that's not really providing their
their nitrogen requirements in addition
there's this all also this consideration
of adding this high carbon mix back into
your soil which can soak up your other
nitrogen so it's it makes it makes sense
that these corn and soy growers are not
reporting that as as frequently however
they are seeing this benefit using the
cover crops as a source of animal forage
so corn and soy is a big dairy feed crop
right so these farmers have cows on the
farm they're feeding them every day they
figure hey we can throw a cover crop
that protects the soil and also feeds
the cows like that's a double-edged
sword so to speak vegetable growers are
not really seeing that as much maybe
because they don't have the animals
incorporated into the system that's
frequently and we ask the same question
about these the profitability overall
and got a similar response again very
few are saying this is a not not a
profitable practice um well a lot are
saying yeah it's profitable or has a
neutral impact so again this comes down
to the balance of those positive and
negative aspects that I talked about
with the partial budget analysis and
kind of everything boiling down to is
this investment paying off
and so the second big question that we
asked with this survey is how long does
it take to see some of these benefits so
soils generally change pretty slowly
we've all heard the you know the numbers
about how quickly soil can be eroded but
how long it takes for us to build
topsoil to build that organic matter
back so we're really interested in
finding out how long it takes for those
farmers to see that extra income that
that increased yield that reduced
irrigation requirements and what we did
is we broke down all the respondents in
each of these pools into experience
levels from one to five years five to
ten years ten to twenty years and more
than twenty years and we got a good a
good representation across all of those
time periods and we used that to to
evaluate the point in time at which
these farmers are seeing these benefits
so this is probably the strongest
relationship that we saw which
interestingly is not necessarily related
to soil health but it is related to
income and benefits that these farmers
might be seeing there's several
different cost share options out there
that farmers can tap into to help cover
the cost of doing these practices
because there's policies conservation
policies that are trying to provide wild
wildlife habitat and protect these water
resources so they're helping farmers do
these practices and interestingly what
we saw is that the highest percentage of
farmers accessing these programs are in
the most experienced group whereas it's
the opposite with the one to five year
group which is kind of unfortunate
because what we really want is is to be
helping these farmers get going and
helping them get these practices in
place and that's really why these why
these policies exist is to to get things
off the ground a little bit so
um I think maybe this reflects the
difficulty that some farmers have
navigating these policies and
understanding them and understanding how
to tap into them and hopefully this will
be be useful for policy makers and
realizing that they need to do a better
job of making these early adopters aware
of these programs and getting them
involved we saw a similar pattern with
respect to less erosion and
sedimentation repair so this is again
reduced tillage and so we're not
disturbing the soil as much not breaking
up the slope or is not oxidizing that
organic matter and therefore we're
creating better infiltration better
Waterland from the infiltration and
seeing less erosion and we're seeing
that that grows over time almost 200
percent in music these two more
experienced groups but we're also seeing
that there is frequently an immediate
effect
even within the one to five year group
here so oh I'd say that's over 60% of
reduced tillage practitioners are seeing
an immediate effect on their on their
erosion issues and this is using the
chi-square test we we saw that this was
significant association and then looking
at the delay period for benefits of
cover crops so again this is a little
bit of a different mechanism these cover
crops are covering the soil holding it
in place and interestingly we did not
really see a strong pattern here you can
see the p-value is 0.6 so it doesn't
really look like there's an association
but initially more than 75% are saying
yeah growing cover crops is reducing my
erosion and that's consistent for the
next 20 plus years so cover crops this
showing cover crops are are immediately
effective in reducing erosion
this is a another graph looking at these
these different experience levels here
and we're seeing greater yields among
these farmers who have been using cover
crops longer and this could reflect the
length of time that it takes those cover
crops to to impact the soil health in
tangible ways but also we're seeing you
know a bit a bit of a bit of that even
among the early adopters here and this
is a pretty decent p-value so we think
there's an association there and this is
the converse of that last slide so this
was greater yields of cash crops being
more prevalent among the more
experienced groups here we're seeing
lower yields of cash crops more
prevalent among the early adopters but
then it quickly drops off so really none
of these none of these more experienced
practitioners we're reporting reduce
yields because only in the the early
adopter group here so I think those two
slides together really complete that
picture of the initial investment maybe
there's an initial cost but quickly your
yields should bounce back and an
increase so finally the third question
that we looked at was the resilience of
these the resilience that farmers were
seeing to some extreme weather events so
we asked them about the ability of their
cover crop practices the reduced tillage
and their soil amendment practices to
mitigate a really heavy downfall or
really heavy rainfall flooding and
drought and so here just as an example
of what can happen
heavy rainfall maybe you'll get a couple
inches within an hour and that can
really I'll pretty much submerge your
crop if your soil is not absorbing that
precipitation and on the other end of
the spectrum we see here a farmer in
September looking at his his corn
field that hasn't gotten rain in several
months and is severely impacted by that
by a drought so so both of these
situations could potentially be
mitigated with healthy soil and so the
responses that we got we're interesting
in that a majority over 60% of farmers
who are using either cover crops to
reduce tillage are saying across the
board yeah it's helping prevent flooding
it's helping helping reduce the impacts
of drought and it's helping reduce
erosion we also looked at amendments
here which referred to mostly manure
compost biochar and we're seeing really
not as not as good performance here not
surprisingly but we are seeing a little
bit of drought was that resilience there
from the amendments which i think is
probably a result of kind of the
mulching effect and moisture retention
that mulch can have on the surface and
also the organic matter that it's adding
so I'm gonna wrap things up and
mention our website here New York soil
health org we have funding from Cal's as
well as AG in markets and we work with a
wide variety of stakeholders just want
to mention David Wolfe who's a big part
of this study Matt Ryan Harold Venice
are also P is Aaron Bristow is no longer
with us but he worked with us on this
quite a bit and then we're also working
with Johanna Scalia and Thomas Bjorkman
Greg Peck and of course many others as
well from NRCS and Cornell Cooperative
Extension not to mention nonprofits
policymakers people like that so I want
to thank you for coming and try to
answer any questions that you might have
[Applause]
I don't think that was included
I do have actually I should mention I do
have copies of the survey and you can
see it's one piece of paper so it's it
can get kind of overwhelming when you're
when you're approaching these farmers
and asking them to spend 10 or 15
minutes filling out a form that they
don't really have to and so it's really
struggle to kind of fit everything on
here
I think that there were a lot of
questions that we would have liked to
ask so but you're referring mostly to
cover crops right so I mean what would
be the what would be the relevance of
that in terms of be the economic picture
right yeah I mean the challenge is
there's so many different types of farms
out there and they've all got different
types of equipment they're all planning
a different cover crop mix into a
different cash crop how did you like
it's it's really complicated I think
that could be that could be really
useful if you have a targeted pet like a
really targeted question and you really
target specific like you could say okay
say I want to compare the costs and
benefits of farmers planting Rai into
our interceding Rai in the corn and soy
versus a vegetable grower who's taking
something out of rotation and planting
peas or something you know like that's
even though they're both cover crops
they're totally different so I mean
that's that's a good point that this
this really covers everything and so
it's you know that's that's one of the
good things about it is it gives us a
big picture but the drawback is we can't
really pick out those those details with
this type of like broad approach I think
there's definitely all kinds of
opportunities for that I think it's very
likely
so we advertised the survey through
newsletters which gets sent into farmers
email inboxes so it's yeah it's very
it's very much cell selected but I did
also go to a lot of conferences and
farmer meetings where there were maybe a
hundred people in the room and we all
sort of took some time as part of the
meeting to do that so I think that was
that was a good thing in that it
encouraged people who otherwise wouldn't
have bothered to fill it out and of
course you know like one of the results
was 125 of the 182 indicated that they
used cover crops which is totally
disproportional to the other numbers of
of cover crops that we think are out
there so it's good for the survey
because we got a lot of responses
relevant to these practices but yeah I
think that is an issue and I think that
really that really comes into play in
terms of those profitability pie charts
because that's not necessarily
representative of the entire population
Shannon yeah it's a possibility I think
that that would be an interesting way to
maybe touch on Peters idea about getting
into the nitty-gritty details of the
cover crops that are being used and and
more suppose the more specific methods
yeah that's definitely a possibility
Harold
so category corn in 20 so there's sort
of a category farmers here in New York
that are corn and soybean growers and
are primarily grain growers and then
there are dairy farmers who grow corn
and right so you separate those out
visit ok so I quit I just like minimum
tillage dairy farm the needs are
different or cover crops a lot of the
dairy farmers so the categories stages I
I think if I'm asking if I understand
your question you're asking our silage
corn considered the same crop as grain
corn right already to say you can ignore
the corners maybe include well actually
what we did is we so we used I think
eight different crop groups here grains
oil seed dry beans corn and soybean for
feed tree fruit berry crops etc and
those were taken from the census
categories I believe so we did specify
corn and soybean for feed ok so I think
that kind of brings up an interesting
point in that the language that you use
in the survey is really important
because it's up to the farmer to read
what's printed on the paper and try to
interpret that so there's definitely a
little bit of kind of wiggle room and
maybe you know maybe a farmer just
glances over it and puts it in another
category or something I
um but I guess grain corn could I mean I
mean grain corn could be for feed right
I mean the ultimate wreck ultimate place
where it ends up maybe maybe four feet
but I guess I'm the reason why I bring
it up it is it's forty thirty farmers
and they well they often have a
perennial crop in there already and then
they they are applying manure and they
it's a lot easier for them to establish
a cover crop after corn silence because
they have a lot more time a lot of them
actually are required to do it because
over their CAFO plan and corn and
soybean growers that's a green grower
and a green might end up in an animal
somewhere but they they are initially
selling it to an elevator and they have
sores are growing for great horned a
corn for breaking story then they have
that long season like you were saying
which is really right because there you
go challenge in terms of using the other
crops right okay does the cook does the
corn have to dry maybe try down a little
bit before yeah I mean Simon kid hard
was it
around this time almost of it's already
been harvested grain might stay until
the middle of October and then you might
you might be able to get some rind it's
just unless you used interested yeah
yeah that's that's one of the challenges
of doing a survey like this is trying to
cover everything but also not mix things
up too much yeah yeah like for example
you know berries on here could be
blueberries or it could be strawberries
ones it's I mean the I guess they're
both perennials but strawberries are
treated more as annuals than blueberries
are per se so there's things are kind of
lumped together a little bit in ways
that might not necessarily make a whole
lot of sense but you kind of have to go
with with the resources it resources
that you have in the space and the paper
that you have but again you know that's
that is that could be a whole other
study is looking at just corn growers
and and trying to pick apart the
different Covercraft practices that are
out there for sure Jonathan I have a
question about your time domain you got
a lot of responses based upon you know
the performance evaluation for a lot of
different things but the only time the
main you have is really serve
experiential on the farmers part do you
have anything about when they has
established the whenever's conservation
to whatever happens to be the practices
that they're putting in so they're
rather than experiential time-aligned
you actually yeah in practice timeline
so you can have some of those types of
responses I'm not sure I completely
understand the question so you have a
grower who's got twenty years of
experience but they've only established
I will do whatever happened to the last
five years right okay so yeah so so
there could be a difference between how
much experience you have versus how long
have you been doing this on your farm
right right
the way we worded the question I mean I
actually did think of that and the way
we word the question because we wanted
we wanted the we wanted to capture the
benefits that that person was seeing on
the farm that they were reporting for
right so there we asked them ask them to
report for their primary farm which we
kind of defined a little bit in the
survey so it could be conceivable that a
farmer might have sort of 30 years of
experience growing cover crops but
recently relocated to their farm and so
that was that was kind of a problem that
we considered but the way that we worded
it was
you
approximately how many years have you
used cover crops on your farm and and we
asked them to report the information on
the survey survey for their farm and and
so the response in that case would have
been 1 to 5 5 to 10 10 to 15 okay right
I thought really is hearing some farmer
is really experienced of cover crops
correct yeah yeah I guess I used that
experience as you're right maybe there's
a better word for that I actually think
that's a better way of getting the data
anyway but it could it could be but yeah
but then you're sort of also asking the
farmer are they reporting for you know
this this other farm that that they do
contract work with where they plant
cover crops or it just kind of got a
little complicated when we started to
dig into that issue but that I mean
that's that's that's concern for sure is
how do you how do you capture the data
that you want think Peter right so some
people so some respondents said yeah I
have cover crops in my board system
basically that's that's a little bit of
a gray area I think cuz it could be the
cover crop itself they could be growing
sturdy kale as a cover crop and that is
the forage
that was that was definitely a challenge
of the survey is like how do we how do
we include those so so some farmers I
think assumed oh I'm just I'm just I've
got some hay acreage and I'm just making
hay and that's a cover crop like I'm
keeping the soil covered you know and
somebody else might be saying oh I'm
actually tilling and then planting
alfalfa every five years or something
and planting a cover crop in between or
something like that so I think that
that's there was kind of everything
okay this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu